Let's go instead to our caller from the 9
7 2 area code.
Who's calling from 9 7 to.
By David is Daniel from Texas, Zoe Daniel,
what's going on?
I have a question for you.
So I'm a big advocate of Medicare for all.
Like many of your listeners and yourself,
one of the questions that come up from our
friends and family is should it be included
in a Medicare for all option or whatever plan
we come up with that we are including all
of the insurance employees as part of retraining
or even bringing them onto a government ran
system?
Or should it be included in the budgeting
for that or how would you picture that?
A the Democratic Party, since they'll be the
ones that end up pushing it through, how do
you plan that they will do it versus how do
you think it should be done to incorporate
all those people who lose their jobs?
Well, here's the thing.
A lot of the people that work in the health
insurance industry don't really need to be
retrained in this.
They're going to need to find new jobs for
sure.
But it's not really the training piece that
they need help with.
What I mean by that is so everyone who's as
a service provider would just continue like
if you're a doctor, you stay a doctor.
If you're a nurse, you stay indoors.
Okay.
Executive level people, human resources people,
you know, all of these people that work at
health insurance companies there, their skills
would still be in demand, as is at other companies.
We would just need to find other companies
for them.
So certainly that would be a piece of it.
There's really only a slice of healthcare
company employees that would really need retraining.
I mean, OK, maybe you don't need nearly as
many medical billing people and that's a really
specific narrow job that would be less relevant.
You'll still need some of them because remember,
single payer still involves billing.
It's just that there's one payer.
So I actually don't know that retraining is
really the thing.
I think it's going to be more a jobs program
to figure out where are they going to go?
Do they get involved in government infrastructure
programs?
Do we transition them over to green energy?
Stuff like that is a question.
I don't know that retraining is really the
issue.
I agree and I agree with that.
I just kind of wanted to set the stage there
for your thoughts on it.
And do you think do you think that the numbers.
Should be included in any budget.
So we have debates or discussions about that
regarding the cost of that.
Or do you see it already shown in those numbers?
I don't know the answer as to whether it's
already in the numbers.
I just simply don't know.
God, in my belief, because I want to be transparent
is.
Yeah.
If we think about what it's going to cost
to do Medicare for all, I want to include
in that.
Whatever costs we are including to transition
a lot of the people that will lose their jobs
over to Newt.
I would include that.
Now Republicans in bad faith would simply
say, oh, so it costs even more than you said,
right.
I mean so but so.
So for political reasons, maybe it's best
not to include it.
But if I really want to holistically think
about what's the total cost here, I would
include the transition costs for how the government
will support healthcare company employees
moving elsewhere.
Great, thank you.
Have a good one.
All right.
Appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.
OK.
I don't have time to take more calls today,
but I will take calls again.
And I really appreciate everybody who called
in.
Hope to hear from you very, very soon.